now that the game is over if you're
about to head anywhere in the valley no
surcharges for ride share services are
rising madison kimbrough been tracking
these ever since the game started live
near legion stadium with an overview on
those surcharges madison
okay brian we are out here and as you
can see we are in the hustle and bustle
and it is very loud so i couldn't hear
you earlier but take a look at the
excitement is out here as the raiders
pull out with a win but as far as how
these fans are going to get back home we
just checked rideshare surcharges and
prices look reasonable while the price
obviously depends on where you want to
go
now here at allegiant stadium many
people may choose to walk longer
distances as prices increase but we also
noticed several lots with parking
available and to our surprise we saw a
lot offering parking for just 20 dollars
that's the lowest we've seen thus far at
any raters game here at allegiant
stadium
now coming up in the six o'clock we plan
on talking to some more fans to see what
issues they may be facing as they head
home but i'm telling you everyone is in
great spirit as you can see people are
walking back from the stadium just happy
that we pulled out a win sending it back
to you guys